A few moments ago,
before I walked onstage,
I was aware that there was this story
playing out in my head.
It was actually a dance
between two stories.
One story was noticing
the size of this audience
and the cameras that are around,
and was telling me that now would not be
a good time to trip over a shoelace
or forget any lines.
And the other story in my head
was telling me to be grateful
for this opportunity.
Go out, relish the experience,
and have fun.
I was aware that whichever story took hold
might impact the next
12 minutes of my life
and determine how this talk unfolds.
Therapists and psychologists tell us
that the stories we tell ourselves
play a fundamental role in how we interact
with the world around us.
Some people tell themselves
that they are not enough.
Other people tell themselves
that they're impostors.
And if you've ever seen the auditions
of a television singing competition,
some people tell themselves
they're a little better
than they actually are.
But apart from the individual stories
we tell ourselves,
all of us are also taking part
in larger, collective stories
that shape our behavior as a species.
A collective story enables people in India
to treat cows as sacred,
while people in America
cram cows into feedlots.
Our internal and external worlds
are full of stories
that shape our behaviors.
Today, I want to talk
about a collective story
that most people aren't even aware
they're inhabiting.
It is a collective story that tells us
that human beings are separate
and superior to nature.
It is a story that has taken us so close
to the brink of an unimaginable crisis
that our survival now depends
on telling a new story.
So ...
Once upon a time, in a land far away --
and right here, actually,
on the lands that we're gathered today,
the majority of people on planet Earth
had a deep reverence
and respect for nature.
They saw very little separation
between themselves
and the world around them.
Many cultures saw nature
as a giving parent.
The plants and the animals
were their relatives.
Indigenous Australians saw themselves
as custodians of the land,
while the ancient Chinese
considered themselves
reverent guests of nature.
Even prominent figures of Rome,
like Ovid and Seneca,
argued that mining
shouldn't be permissible,
as it was too abusive
to the natural world.
But then, things started to change.
A new craze called Christianity
began to take hold.
Word spread that their one God
sat above and outside nature,
and that God had made people
in his own image
and given them dominion over the Earth.
"Sounds alright," said the people,
passing on the news
to friends and relatives,
missionaries, kings.
"The world was made for the sake of man,
that it may serve him,"
said the bishop of Paris
in the early 12th century.
The Christian craze
had now infiltrated Europe
and was beginning its march
into the Americas.
"But wait, there's more,"
said a couple of fancy-looking men
in the early 1600s.
They told the people that they were
from the Scientific Revolution,
and that they could empower
the people even further.
"We must hound nature in her wanderings,"
said the first man --
Francis Bacon,
the father of modern science.
"We must find a way, at length,
into her inner chambers.
We must reveal the secrets
still locked in nature's bosom.
Make her your slave,
subdue her,
shake her to her foundations."
"Yes," said the men. "It sounds alright."
The second man then chimed in.
His name was René Descartes,
the father of modern philosophy.
He confirmed to the people that, yes,
they were superior to nature
and added that animals
were mindless machines to be mastered
and exploited at will.
"Well, that's a relief," said the people.
"Now, we don't have to feel so bad
about whipping our oxen."
The influence of these two men,
coupled with the religious craze,
meant that nature was no longer
seen as a living thing
to be revered and respected,
but instead as a machine to be manipulated
for the benefits of mankind.
This was a new and exciting story
that set free natural resources for humans
to achieve social and economic progress,
even if obtained through violent
and suppressive acts.
This new story was particularly enticing
to the emerging capitalists of the time,
because a nature devoid
of reverence and respect
was much easier to commodify.
And commodify they did.
The humans went to work,
entering and penetrating
all of those inner chambers.
They tunneled her bosom
for coal and metals,
they scraped and plowed
over her skin with their tractors.
They took chain saws
to her forests of follicles,
and they filled her waters
with their waste.
The new story had spread across the globe.
Humans had asserted their dominance,
they built wondrous things
and improved the lives
of billions of people,
particularly in specific regions.
Until one day ...
their scientists began to notice.
"Her animals are decreasing."
"Her atmosphere is heating."
"The soils are eroding."
"Our research is foreboding."
But still, the humans carried on.
You see, they couldn't hear
the scientists,
because the facts don't matter much
if they don't fit the story.
And the story was deeply embedded now.
In 2019, the head of the Environmental
Protection Agency in the US
opposes regulations because, he says,
"We have a responsibility to harvest
the natural resources
that we've been blessed with."
A prominent evangelist tells his followers
that refusing to use fossil fuels
hurts God's feelings.
The story was so embedded
that the humans' nightly news bulletins
measured their success
by financial metrics alone,
while the living world that allowed
the gains in those metrics
was being eviscerated out of sight.
And the story was so embedded
that when researchers looked
at the names of trees, birds, flowers
and other keywords relating to nature,
used across millions
of books, songs and movies,
from 1900 to 2014 ...
they found a dramatic decline
in the use of those words
across that period.
The humans were spending
seven hours a day on their screens.
So not only were they experiencing
fewer stories and actual
experiences of nature ...
but they were being bombarded
by up to 10,000 advertisements a day,
largely for products that are inflicting
even more ecological damage.
Nature was being hounded
in her wanderings.
And yet, the humans remain
trapped in their story.
Trapped in their cultural programming ...
like goldfish in a tank,
unaware of the unfolding chaos
beyond the colored pebbles
and the artificial logs.
So when those same scientists
resorted to blocking traffic
and tying themselves to poles
or screaming that the Amazon rainforest,
the most spectacular of all her forests,
was nearing a tipping point
that would turn her into a savanna ...
still, the humans did nothing.
Because to them, those trees ...
those trees that were home
to thousands of species of animals
and millions of species of insects,
those trees that sent
nutrients to each other
via underground fungal networks ...
those trees that transpired moisture
into the air to create rainfall
that would feed crops in countries
thousands of kilometers away ...
those trees were just ...
timber for decking.
Pulp for toilet paper.
Or space for more cows.
Those trees were worth more
dead than alive ...
because that's what the story
had told them.
But then, something remarkable happened.
It started with the children,
who began to skip school
and take to the streets.
It started with the farmers
who chose to stop fighting nature
and instead rebuild their soils.
It started when the Indigenous people,
who, for centuries, had been reminding
everybody of their story,
were finally being listened to.
And it started when nature herself,
through fires and storms,
through droughts and rising waters,
forced her way back
into the people's lives
and demanded their respect.
A new, regenerative story
about human beings and nature
was emerging.
But of course,
it wasn't a new story at all.
It was the retelling of an old story.
But this time,
the old story was supported
by the science.
And it was telling the people
that every breath they took
was dependent on trees
and phytoplankton,
And that trillions of bacteria and fungi
lived on them and in them
and kept them alive.
Viewing the natural world
as separate to humans
was now empirically false.
Humans are nature.
But the science was also telling them
that plants could see,
they could smell, hear ...
they could learn and store memories.
That dolphins gossiped
and spoke in local dialects,
elephants held ceremonies
for dead relatives,
grasshoppers could turn into locusts
and back again in a matter of hours,
and that termites had built
an underground metropolis
the size of the United Kingdom.
The same scientific inquiry that had led
to domination and extraction
had gone so deep into nature's bosom
that it was revealing her secrets.
And her secrets were divulging
that she was anything but mechanistic.
That she was deserving
of the utmost reverence and respect.
And that the original story
had been right all along.
And so perhaps now,
the humans would no longer refer to nature
as an unruly female to be tamed
or an "it" to be exploited ...
but would refer to nature simply ...
as kin.
Nobody knows how this new
but old story ends
because it is still being written.
But if it is to have the Hollywood ending,
if we are to break free
from our cultural programming
and pull off the miraculous comeback
when all seems lost,
then the new but old story will have to be
rapidly spread throughout the culture.
It will need to be embedded
into all levels of curriculum,
particularly at the early stages,
so children can see the world
as a living system,
not as a machine
full of stocks and commodities.
It will need to inform
a redesign of the economy,
so it values nature
and reflects the true environmental costs
of the materials we all use.
It will need to revamp
the nightly news bulletins
so we'd measure soil health,
atmospheric pollution, species loss
alongside the financial metrics.
And crucially,
the new but old story
will need to be amplified
by the storytellers.
The musicians, the artists,
those that can create
the emotional connection
to the living world once again,
and paint visions
of a nature-filled future
that people can see
and feel and strive for.
Because stories shape culture.
Culture shapes leaders,
leaders shape policies,
and policies shape the system.
And perhaps,
just perhaps, one day ...
a few hundred years from now ...
historians will look back to this moment,
and they'll see that,
amongst the chaos and the nihilism
and the fear and the extinctions
that there were groups of people
who chose to turn the page
and begin to write
a new chapter for humanity.
A chapter full of diverse characters,
from a range of professions and places,
who came together
to create a thriving,
regenerative,
ecological future.
The end.
(Cheers and applause)